politique et le président de la
République va-t-il décider de parler ou
plutôt de garder le silence il
intervient en tout cas ce soir dans le
journal de TF1 après la série de
révélations concernant le financement
occulte des partis politiques et surtout
du RPR le chef de l'État que certains
pressent de s'expliquer alors que ça
fonctionne le préserve de répondre à la
justice dans quelles affaires est-il mis
en cause réponse avec Zinédine Boudaoud
sur son bureau 4 dossiers brûlent les
doigts du chef de l'État 4 dossiers
judiciaires en cours d'instruction des
goupillé donc comme des grenades qui
menacent de lui exploser au visage ses
affaires remontent autant au Jacques
Chirac était maire de Paris jusqu'en
1995 j'appelle Monsieur Jacques Chirac
et lui maire de Paris à prendre place au
fauteuil de la présidence et a
poursuivre et dans ces dossiers le nom
du chef de l'État apparaît en filigrane
est parfois même en toutes lettres
premier dossier le plus retentissant
celui des HLM de Paris instruit par Eric
alphène depuis 6 ans le juge de Créteil
s'attache à démontrer que les marchés
publics de l'office HLM ont servi à
alimenter les caisses du RPR en échange
de l'obtention des marchés truqués les
entreprises reversaient une commission à
des intermédiaires le plus important
d'entre eux Jean-Claude Méry collecteur
occulte du mouvement gaulliste qui
confirme les soupçons de la justice dans
la fameuse cassette vidéo révélée en
septembre dernier pour la première fois
il mettait en cause le chef de l'État et
son homme de confiance Michel Roussin
les poursuites engagées à l'encontre de
Michel Roussin directeur de cabinet du
maire de Paris à l'époque des fées ont
été récemment annulés par la cour
d'appel les gentibéry premier adjoint de
Chirac et président de l'OPAC et
poursuivi pour trafic d'influence
réaction à la fois sur la forme et sur
le fond
je suis
indigné par le procédé
indigné par le mensonge
indigné par l'outrans
aujourd'hui on rapporte une histoire
abracadabrantes deuxième dossier
l'affaire des marchés des lycées
d'Île-de-France le système est identique
au précédent avec une différence de
taille les détournements organisés
autour des marchés de construction et de
rénovation des lycées de la région
parisienne auraient profité à plusieurs
formations politiques
au RPR qui présidait le conseil régional
d'Île-de-France la part du lion au parti
républicain au Parti socialiste et aux
partis communistes le reste
Michel Roussin aurait supervisé ce
système de trucage lui s'en défend mais
plusieurs dépositions à la câbles c'est
ce qui a conduit ce fidèle de Jacques
Chirac en prise en quelques jours Louis
Yvonne casseta la trésorière officieuse
du RPR y a sans doute échappé de peu
c'est qu'elle a consenti au juge un aveu
Jacques Chirac était au courant des dons
des entreprises au parti madame Casetta
veut parler des dons légaux aussitôt
corrigé son défenseur 600 millions de
commissions aurait été en tout cas été
versées
troisième dossier les emplois fictifs de
la Ville de Paris l'instruction est
menée à Nanterre depuis 4 ans par le
juge Patrick desmur au cours d'une
perquisition à l'Hôtel de Ville l'an
dernier les policiers retrouvent la
preuve la plus compromettante pour
l'ancien maire de Paris une note de
service datée de 1993 dans laquelle le
maire Jacques Chirac intervient en
faveur de la promotion d'une employée de
la ville problème cette femme salariée
par la ville est en fait une permanente
du RPM de quoi poursuivre peut-être
Jacques Chirac pour prise illégal
d'intérêt écrit le procureur de Nanterre
saisi la Cour de cassation met-elle en
suspens le cas du chef de l'État en
décidant de ne pas trancher dans ce
dossier Michel Roussin Louis Yvonne
cassetta mais aussi Alain Juppé ancien
patron du RPR sont mis en examen
quatrième dossier la sympa du nom d'une
société d'économie mixte chargée de tous
les travaux d'imprimerie de la ville de
Paris ouverte il y a trois ans cette
instruction met en évidence d'important
détournements de fonds malgré trois
rapports d'inspection des dansants les
dérives de la société d'économie mixte
le maire Chirac n'a pourtant jamais
réagi les organes de contrôle comme la
préfecture non plus qui tremblait à
l'idée de poser des questions
embarrassantes à Jacques Chirac Premier
ministre à l'époque c'est ce que
démontre cette note interne ces quatre
dossiers judiciaires sont encombrants
pour le chef de l'État aujourd'hui la
plupart de ces fidèles sont mis à mal
par la justice une justice décidait à
faire la lumière sur la part d'ombre du
successeur de François Mitterrand à
l'Élysée